congressman and civil rights activist
John Lewis says his cancer diagnosis his
one more fight he will take on
correspondent Jonathan Serrie has the
story as an icon of the civil rights
movement Democrat John Lewis has never
shied from a challenge now fighting for
his life
Lewis plans to continue representing
Georgia's fifth congressional district
while undergoing treatment for Stage
four pancreatic cancer
he explains while I'm clear-eyed about
the prognosis doctors have told me that
recent medical advances have made this
type of cancer treatable in many cases
the treatment options are no longer as
debilitating as they once were and that
I have a fighting chance former
President Barack Obama tweeted if
there's one thing I love about
representative John Lewis
it's his incomparable will to fight I
know he's got a lot more of that left in
him a fighter is how colleagues on both
sides of the aisle describe Lewis who in
2016 led Democrats in a surprise sit-in
in the House chamber to call for gun
control two decades before his election
to Congress in 1986 Lewis suffered a
fractured skull in the bloody sunday
march across Selma Alabama Edmund Pettus
Bridge which helped galvanize support
for the Voting Rights Act of 1965
congressman Lewis showed great love in
the face of violence and brutality and
so we are praying with great compassion
for congressman Lewis the warrior I'll
always remember him as the gentle yet
very strong warrior North Carolina
Republican Mark Walker tweeted a photo
of himself and Lewis at a recent
commemoration of the Selma March rioting
it was one of the greatest honors of my
life to walk by his side across this
bridge and I will do the same as he
crosses his next Lewis said he may have
to miss some House votes while
undergoing cancer treatment over the
next several weeks but with prayers and
God's grace he hopes to be back on the
frontline soon Mike Jonathan thank you
very much